bret baier such heroes politics here at
fox always happy to have them on our
show
joins us on set tonight where are we in
this yeah I'm talking to sources inside
Iraq inside the US government here's
what we know we know that two bases have
been struck by the Iranians with
missiles from Iran which in and of
itself is a huge excess collation many
people thought that the attacks would be
coming from proxies inside Iraq these
are fired from Iran but the choice of
those two bases is interesting one was
al Assad which is in the Sunni
stronghold of Alumbaugh province
the other one is Erbil which is the
Kurdish capital they don't have as many
US forces as Balad which is a major base
that's actually closer to Iran is this a
signal is this a message is it because
the Sunnis and the Kurds were supporting
the US and against the Shia in the Iraqi
parliament who we can say is if you're
Iran and you wanted to inflict maximum
damage on American troops in Iraq you
don't have hit a different base and it
would have been easier balada a major
base and it's closer to a wrong I'm
reading through the tea leaves so it's
saying that we'll see what the damage
assessment is but if as reported that no
US casualties right we don't know if the
Iraqis took casualties of either one of
these bases I think what you're seeing
here from your source on the ground in
Baghdad it could be you know more about
the Iranian Shia militias that support
Iran that may be active inside Baghdad
which we saw during the Iraq war for
sure it was a defining factor so how is
this and again this is moving even as we
speak
but the extent we can tell now how is
this affecting the the presidential race
currently in progress how is that
breaking down I think we have yet to see
I think that this is the biggest test
for President Trump as a leader it is by
far his biggest test as you know he
campaigned on a getting out of the
Middle East of bringing troops home this
is his moment to decide how far to push
this what the response is and what that
response will be will dictate how the
rest of the world reacts
as far as the politics it changed the
Democratic race significantly you've
seen Bernie Sanders go far hard on this
Iran issue Joe Biden is trying to ride
the rails but he has his own issues
about what the Obama administration did
with Iran and the red line and the
paying of money to Iranian officials so
it's not I guess what I'm asked it's not
cut and dry it's not it's not it's it's
hard as just someone watching this who's
not covering politics full-time anymore
as you are to see how it doesn't seem
like the Democrats are all the way on
one side of Republicans all the way on
the other it's more confusing than that
100% and the fact that we are now in an
election year that we are three and a
half weeks away from the Iowa caucuses
this is a major event that will have big
repercussions but most importantly the
next steps on the ground in Iraq in Iran
and whether those targets inside Iran
maybe that shot those missiles will be
in the sights of u.s. warplanes we don't
know so is it cleared the the White
House I hate to use the phrase talking
points but position like if if you were
to sit down with the president or one of
his advisers and say you know what's our
plan going forward is it clear what the
answer would be or is that the purpose
do you think of the president addressing
the nation tonight that's the purpose if
an if and when he does it that that'll
be a clear here's where we are this is
what I'm thinking
notice we didn't hear anything from the
gang of eight or anybody up on Capitol
Hill after they were briefed by
officials the whole House and Senate
expected to be briefed tomorrow on the
intelligence that led to the taking out
of Soleimani based on what they said was
an imminent attack that was coming I
think there's heavy skepticism up on
Capitol Hill and in different corners
and maybe that's what the president's
going to address he's going to address
why we did it yeah and maybe next steps
I mean this is the moment where the
country is going to want to know where
are we going from here the damage
assessment by now they have a decent
sense of what it looks like on the
ground so I know you're not in the
editorial izing business but tell me if
you can confirm this instinct my sense
is of the president that he's not
interested in some kind of protracted
war with Iran certainly not a ground
that he's not you know his his instincts
are restraint is that what you're
sensing or hearing policy-wise what he
can't paint on that's what he suggests
but what he says verbally about you know
being tough against Iran what he tweets
out sends a different message
yeah so whether his rhetoric matches up
with what the policy decision is going
to be tonight I think is the key moment
for this president as commander in chief
and last question do you think we are
going to hear from the president tonight
I would guess that we would because it's
that big of a moment yes and and listen
having covered the Pentagon for a long
time there's a lot of stuff happening
behind the scenes there's all kinds of
targets that have already been chosen
the question is whether we are going to
step to that next level and what are
responsible in this being Washington in
Washington being fundamentally
bureaucratic a lot of Pentagon employees
including uniformed were sent home today
which is really because of a snowstorm
that never really materialized because
once again this is the federal
government it's unbelievable at one
o'clock it was a ghost town there was
nobody there as this all was happening
the the public relations office
apparently was closed down it was like
tumbleweeds going through the Pentagon
it's it's not shocking to those of us
who live here but to the rest of the
country they must be watching with jaws
open but bear great to see you thank you
so much for that